Berchem usually traditionally gets made
the night before and left in the fridge
I find that a little bit too heavy and
slightly stodgy so it's the same
principles but a lot lighter first in
the yogurt
I think live and raw milk yogurt are
best they're packed with calcium enzymes
and probiotics which help your body
absorb nutrients it's interesting
because the kids especially would prefer
their measly with milk by the yogurt
it's so much better for them
I like making it literally ten minutes
before I want to serve it because it
doesn't become stodgy y'all get in apple
juice has a great way of sweetening the
muesli
a couple of tablespoons in give that
little mix now sprinkle in the oats
I like putting two thirds in now to
absorb an almost double in size in the
last third of votes in at the end
oats are low on the glycemic index which
means they slowly release energy to keep
you going right through to lunch I quite
like it when it just falls off the spoon
you can see literally in seconds
it's got take the rest of the oats in so
I've got different textures
now mix that up nicely and it literally
takes three or four minutes to put
together let's go get a dry pan on
almonds incredibly healthy toasting them
even better flavor flake them into the
pan lightly toast them that gives a
really nice sort of crunch to the top of
the music roll them around the pan so
they're evenly toasted out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries summer raspberries
strawberries and so it changes berries
don't just taste great they're packed
with antioxidants and vitamin C and K so
just dot the top of your muse leave with
your blackberries generous on the
blackberries sweetness and tartness
acidic and then just sprinkle over your
nice always quite like a lot of crunch
on top so be generous
that looks fantastic perfect way to
start the day
my quick Bircher muesli doesn't just
taste incredible it makes you feel
fantastic is my ultimate healthy
breakfast there really is no better way
to start the day
[Music]